just a few hours after launching the
biggest invasion of a European country
since the second world war it looked
like business as usual at the Kremlin
Pakistan's prime minister was the guest
but my Vladimir Putin's mind have been
elsewhere
as the two men talked Russia's military
was advancing in Ukraine
these trucks were headed from Crimea to
the Ukrainian border part of an army
that had surrounded a country of 40
million people a country that Russia's
president has said he doesn't think
should exist
in an address to Russians and ukrainians
Putin said his aim was to demilitarize
Ukraine and he made clear his antipathy
for the government in Kiev
I have to also address the Ukrainian
military dear comrades your fathers
grandfathers great grandfathers fought
against the Nazis defending our common
motherland not for today's neo-nazis to
take Bowen Kiev you took the oath of
allegiance to the Ukrainian people not
the Junta Rob in Ukraine and bullying
its own people do not follow its
criminal orders I urge you to
immediately lay down your weapons and go
home
Russia's defense Ministry says it's met
all its targets for Thursday destroying
83 ground facilities of the Ukrainian
military and it insists they're not
targeting civilian areas the high
Precision weapons of the Russian Armed
Forces only destroy the military
infrastructure these are objects of air
defense military airfields Aviation of
the Armed Forces of Ukraine staged video
filming with mass casualties among the
civilian population was filmed in
Ukrainian cities
there have been some attempts in Russia
to protest Against The Invasion several
hundred turned out in Moscow
they're shouting no to war judging the
Russian Public's reaction is difficult
because it's almost impossible to
protest freely here but Vladimir Putin's
approval rating was at 69 in the
build-up to the war this is this is all
blown
[Music]
outlined in his speech what he wants to
get from Ukraine what Ukraine should do
and that included for a total
demilitarization of the country
at an afternoon meeting with businessmen
no one admitted to Vladimir Putin any
worries about sanctions Russia's Central
Bank said it's got 631 billion dollars
in cash reserves to cushion the economy
if it's closed off from the Global
Financial system
late night phone call on Thursday the
French President told Vladimir Putin he
was exposing himself to massive
sanctions the Kremlin said Putin and
Emmanuel macron had a serious and Frank
exchange of views whatever was said it
was unlikely to have been enough to stop
the Russian military's Advance on Kiev
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Moscow